today on the matt walsh show race
hustlers colin kaepernick and eber max
kendy both thoroughly embarrassed
themselves over the weekend exposing the
emptiness and absurdity of their world
views it was a bad weekend for race
hustlers in general and we will revel in
their self-immolations today also
democrats in virginia have all the
momentum going against them heading into
the election on tuesday so they decided
to resort to some good old-fashioned
fraud as kind of their closing argument
there in virginia and a southwest
airlines pilot allegedly says let's go
brandon over the intercom on the plane
and this is apparently a national crisis
plus rumors are swirling about joe
biden's meeting with the pope i feel
duty-bound to discuss those rumors today
and we'll do that and so much more on
the matt walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
you know the word grifter is way
overplayed these days especially online
where the average internet user only has
a vocabulary of 17 words to begin with
any term that makes it into that limited
arsenal will inevitably be utilized with
great and undue frequency the problem is
that terms which were once descriptively
useful end up shorn of all meaning this
has happened with words like trauma and
outrage for example and of course racism
and sexism not to mention the big one
woman
but i don't want to see the word grifter
neutralized and negated in that way as
it's a very expressive illustrative term
and that's why i will not say that race
hustlers like ebermex candy and colin
kaepernick are grifters now on first
blush the description would seem to fit
them as snug and comfortably as a
well-made sweater i mean a grifter after
all is a con artist a swindler a
carnival barker a fleece or a fraudster
both of these men live up to all of
those adjectives
but the other definitional aspect of a
grifter is that he's petty he's small
time he's small scale operating on the
level of a you know pickpocket or a card
shark race hustlers in our country today
however especially the most famous and
visible ones like kendi and kaepernick
and sharpton
and that lawyer who shows up on the
scene nine seconds after any black man
is shot by the cops
they're all running a very large-scale
con
they may be petty people who got into
this game for their own superficial
reasons
personal fame and wealth being the
primary motivators as always but
the effect they have on our society is
anything but smaller petty
they're closer to you know bernie madoff
level than pickpockets
their schemes are sweeping far-reaching
and they've managed to inflict
widespread devastation so it's worth
pausing to appreciate
whenever one of these degenerate
sleazeballs accidentally reveals
themselves for who they are and over the
last few days it just so happens that
two of them both kendi and kaepernick
have done just that so starting with
kendy on friday he shared an article
from the hill published a few days prior
which reports on a survey finding that
more than a third of white college
applicants
lie on their applications in order to
increase their chances of being admitted
amazingly kendi shared this article
along with the caption accurately
describing the survey's findings he
wrote quote more than a third of white
students lie about their race on college
applications and about half of those
applicants lied about being native
american more than three-fourths of
these students who lied about their race
were accepted
what makes this amazing of course
is that this fact completely undermines
kendy's case
indeed it wouldn't be too far to say
that this fact alone
single-handedly dismantles candy's world
view in its entirety
his vision of the world or at least his
vision of western culture
is that it's structured around and
defined by systemic racism against quote
unquote people of color
but how could there be
systemic racism against non-white people
if a white person's way of gaming that
system is to pretend to be non-whites
you're not going to find any analog to
this in the you know history of the
human race there's no analog there's no
nothing comparable
nowhere else on earth at any other point
in history
can you find an example of a minority
group being systemically oppressed and
people own the dominant majority group
responding to that oppression by
pretending to be in the minority group
so they can personally benefit
doesn't make any sense there weren't a
lot of you know non-jews in germany
pretending to be jewish
it would go the other way around you'd
pretend to not be jewish
i don't think you could have gone to
rwanda in the mid 90s and found very
many people pretending to be in an
ethnic minority group there
in fact there weren't any whites
pretending to be black here in america
during segregation
but there are now
because the systemic discrimination cuts
in precisely the opposite direction
so why did kendy share this then
what point did he think it would make
well to understand that you have to
remember that the race hustlers along
with being driven by greed and arrogance
are also died in the wool anti-white
bigots they hate white people
and so for candy all he saw in the
headline was that white people did
something bad you know they lied on an
application and that's as far as as his
thought process went his brain said look
white people did bad thing and he shared
it
only later did he connect the dots or
rather other people connected the dots
and alerted him to the problem so he
responded by deleting the original post
and then a short time later in defending
himself against charges of being a
stupid self-contradicting hypocrite
kendy tweeted this
they
talking about his critics lie about what
i said to defend the lying of white
college applicants here is their
tortured line of thinking
when white applicants think they have an
advantage by lying about being a person
of color
then that means they do have an
advantage which then means structural
racism doesn't exist
they imagine white people are
disadvantaged while white people are on
the higher end of nearly every racial
disparity they imagine black and native
people have racial advantages at the
same time black and native people are on
the lowest end of nearly every racial
disparity smh
well by the way kenny no we're not
saying that uh systemic discrimination
doesn't exist
no we're saying it does exist but that
it exists against white people we're
saying that you benefit from it as a
black man
the problem for kendy is that white
applicants
yeah they think they have an advantage
and in fact actually they do as he said
in his original post more than
three-fourths of the whites who lie
about the race are accepted
whites perceived that it would be to
their advantage if they weren't white
and their perceptions are vindicated by
the results
there are plenty of additional lines of
evidence proving that there is no
systemic racism against non-whites in
this country but this one line of
evidence is perhaps the most powerful
it's conclusive all on its own
if the system is biased against a
certain group you could not possibly
game that system by pretending to be in
that very group period
and so kendy's whole life's work is
reduced to rubble
by his own words which is fantastic
and then there's kaepernick
in kabernick's case uh you know if you
can put aside the moral and ethical
problems for a moment you might almost
have to admire his hustle
it's it's it's
in a way sort of brilliant
that he was he was flunking out of the
nfl let me just think about this think
about think about what happened with
kaepernick
flunking out of the nfl
suffering through a 10-loss season
uh with the 49ers back in 2016. he had
just been benched for blaine gabbert
which is the nfl equivalent of losing a
beauty pageant to you know rachel levine
and he found himself start staring at a
career as a bench writer hopping from
one team to another on one year
contracts
uh getting paid the veteran minimum
which is still like almost a million
dollars
uh but even so in nfl terms pretty
pretty low salary and he decided in that
moment to pivot and become a social
justice crusader instead and the career
change has made him a household name
whereas before he would have been about
as famous and widely discussed as joe
flacco is today
um now he's this famous
household name it's also made him far
richer than he would have been otherwise
with all kinds of promotional deals and
shoe deals and books and everything
he also has his own netflix show now
it's called colin in black and white and
it's being largely hailed by critics
because critics are contractually
obligated to hail anything kaepernick
does but the show has been mocked and
derided by everybody else thanks largely
to one scene which went viral over the
weekend
where kaepernick biting off more than he
could chew
actually compares the nfl draft to a
slave auction
watch this
what they don't want you to understand
is what's being established
is a power dynamic
before they put you on the field
teams poke
pride and examine you searching for any
defect that might affect your
performance no boundary respected
no dignity left intact
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it actually sounds more like he's
describing you know tsa screening
poke pride and examine you no dignity
left intact but no he's describing the
nfl nfl players are slaves he says the
process of becoming an nfl player is
dehumanizing and degrading
which is very different from what he
said literally two weeks ago
when he did an interview with ebony
magazine and claimed that he's still
training every day in hopes of becoming
an nfl player again
this is what he said two weeks ago
he said i'm still up at 5am training
five days a week making sure i'm
prepared to take a team to a super bowl
again that's not something i will ever
let go of regardless of the actions of
32 teams and their partners to deny me
employment
the same way i was persistent in high
school is the same way i'm going to be
persistent here
of course kaepernick can train all he
wants and it's not going to change the
fact he's a 32 year old former backup
who was washed up in 2016 the last time
he played
also the problem with his training is
that it mostly consists of him jogging
through his neighborhood screaming the
word racist at all the trees squirrels
and birds he sees all that aside though
if being an nfl player is like being a
slave
why is he still trying to get into the
nfl
why has he spent six years crying that
he can't be a slave
well because he's full of it of course
slavery and professional football are it
turns out a little bit different
football players are paid millions of
dollars
they get to live in their own homes very
big and expensive homes too
they choose to be football players
that's a big one
they're admired and envied by millions
of adoring fans if kaepernick thinks
that any of this bears any resemblance
to the lot of a slave then his talents
as a historian are even less impressive
than his talents as a quarterback
but he doesn't actually think that
though he's a con artist just saying
whatever he needs to say in the moment
just like candy just like the rest of
them
and it would almost be funny to see them
flailing about like this
funny in a pitiful sort of way
if it weren't for the very real very
widespread damage
that they're doing to our culture
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
as an increasing number of companies
fall over themselves trying to appeal to
the left wouldn't it be nice to find one
that actually supports your values well
i'll tell you about one you've heard
about them many times on the show big
supporters of this show uh charity
mobile is the pro-life phone company
they partner with you to automatically
support the pro-life pro family charity
of your choice with five percent of your
monthly plan price going to the pro
family pro charity of your choice new
activations and eligible accounts also
get a free cell phone free activation
and free shipping
and um you get uh you can even get a new
phone as well you can keep your existing
phone number uh even keep your existing
phone if you want when you switch over
what all it means is that it's not only
are you supporting a company with great
values but you're also getting a great
value
you're getting
a lot of great perks as well monthly
plan prices have just been lowered again
and now you can add even more lines to
family plans there are no contracts
there are no termination fees and no
risk with a 30-day guarantee plus
there's great live customer service and
great nationwide coverage on america's
most reliable network if you want to get
all that then switch to charity mobile
and support the causes that you care
about call them at
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com and mention offer
code walsh okay so uh we celebrated our
10th wedding anniversary by the way on
friday which is why uh there wasn't a
show and last year if you remember i
talked about this for our wedding
anniversary i gave my wife the gift of
not being around
because i had accidentally scheduled a
um speaking gig on the same day as our
anniversary made sure not to do that
this time and so we um
went uh we took a trip for a few days
went on a short trip to asheville north
carolina it's very romantic i think
and on the way up about you know five
hour drive or so i had a chance to uh
monologue extensively to my wife because
i missed the show i didn't do my
monologue so i was monologuing to her i
think at one point i was talking about
um
uh the nature of consciousness and where
it originates in the human mind and the
sort of the physical
um the mind body problem and all that
and
at one point she uh she she suggested
that i monologue in my head so that she
could enjoy the view
and that's how you know you've been
married for 10 years when your spouse
can say to you can you please shut up
and it doesn't offend you at all you
just say yeah that's pretty fair so we
ended up driving the blue ridge parkway
through the mountains in north carolina
and it was again beautiful
though at one point we stopped in an
overlook and the view was uh was was
great you know elevation of 3 500 feet
or so all the leaves were changing
breathtaking stuff
and i looked around at this overlook and
there were a lot of people there
everybody at the overlook they were all
on their phones right using this view as
a as just a a forum as a backdrop for
their social media posts and in fact
this is the first time i'd ever seen
this in the wild first time i'd seen
this and i i was a little bit excited by
this
it was there was somebody
doing a what i assume was a tick-tock
selfie dance video
right there at the overlook
and so i made sure of course to stand
right in the shop my wife was saying can
i have a shot and i just stood there in
the background
as retribution
uh but also because it was my only
chance to ever star in a tick tock
dancing video um but but but mainly as
revenge i mean we're looking at god's
creation
and every every single person there's
probably probably a dozen people all
just looking at their phones or enjoying
the view
through their phone because they want to
get the perfect picture of it so they
can put it online
and then at the next overlook um another
great view
but i took a picture of this myself
um
not to be a hypocrite but on the railing
someone had spray-painted
stolen land right there on the railing
and of course i posed i posed next to it
i told my wife we got to get a shot of
this i never asked to take pictures but
this one shot let's take this so someone
has spray painted stolen land
right there on the railing overlooking
you know and you see again you see the
leaves are changing and everything it's
really beautiful
and i mean all i could say is
man i'm glad we quote unquote stole this
land
now in fairness
conquer
is a little harder to spell than stole
so maybe that's why they went with that
because the appropriate word the right
word to use here is uh we conquered this
land
and when i look out i guess they put
that there so that when we're looking at
the view we're supposed to feel oh i
feel so bad i feel so bad about this
no my reaction is this is fantastic i'm
glad this was this was great land to
conquer
the conquerors made a good choice thank
you very much
and other than that it's great and then
of course we go we go all the way up and
and um we go to the top of the mountain
we're hiking it's like it's like we're
kind of a rainy cold days not a lot of
people we're hiking through the uh the
the trail at the top of the mountains
and then i i saw something that i have
seen in the wild before and that was um
again we're you know high elevation it's
like almost nobody else around
outside in the woods and of course we
see someone walk by uh on the trail in
the woods
with a mask on so
pure pure mental illness
uh
okay we'll start with this speaking of
uh perhaps mental illness this is from
fox it says the disgraced anti-trump
group the lincoln project is facing
intense backlash for
orchestrating the viral hoax involving
tiki torch holding individuals
associating themselves with the yunkan
campaign
twitter you could see them there uh
standing there
twitter was set ablaze after images of a
group wearing white shirts khakis
baseball caps and sunglasses stood
alongside the campaign bus uh virginia
virginia gubernatorial candidate glenn
younkin reportedly vocally expressing
support for the republican
the imagery of the tiki churches was
apparently meant to invoke the white
nationalists who participated in the
deadly events of charlottesville in 2017
and
the stunt was seized upon by the left
including staffers from democrat
candidate terry mcauliffe's campaign
and many of them were were spreading
this was all happening i guess on friday
when i when i was up in the woods
um
and the democrats were were jumping on
this
as republicans are always accused of
seizing and jumping
um piling on but in this case democrats
really didn't say oh look at this
clearly
you see glenn glenn junkins a racist all
these people with tiki torches showing
up to his campaign events
and any any anybody with a brain any
smart rational person
who saw this before it was exposed as
the fraud it clear it was
clearly would have known
you should be able to look at that
i mean there are some dead giveaways
just in that picture alone
that these are not white supremacists
i mean there's there's in particular one
one specific dead giveaway that these
are not white supremacists uh so you
should have known that
and of course everyone did know that the
media knew that but they still spread
this around until finally it was
revealed that um
this was a
stunt well i'm going to use the word
revealed in quotes here it was revealed
that this was supposedly a stunt
by the
lincoln project
but this is only there this is the
lincoln project took credit for it they
said they did this
and uh they called it a stunt
like they're just trying to send a
message they're trying to make a point
about glenn younkin about how he's a
racist somehow
um but we don't actually know that we
don't we don't actually know that the
lincoln project is are the ones who did
this they say they were
or that this was meant to be a stunt
now if i were to theorize it seems much
more likely that this was a fraud
it was a hoax okay a fraud and a hoax
are not the same thing as a stunt
because when you do a stunt everybody
knows it's a stunt
so if they'd showed up there with the
tiki torches and were were saying uh
glenn junk is a racist this is what he
supports that would be a stunt
but when you try to pass it off as real
now it's and especially in the context
of an election a few days before an
election this is now a fraud this is a
hoax
it's the kind of thing
that we're told the democrats would
never do
i mean to accuse democrats of any kind
of election related fraud
now you can't say that you get kicked
off of youtube or twitter for saying
that
this is very clearly a fraud and uh i
frankly don't believe that the lincoln
project they may have been involved but
the idea that they did this on their own
with no coordination with the mcculloch
camp mcauliffe campaign i don't i don't
personally believe that
it seems clear to me
reasonable assumption here based on
context clues and circumstantial
evidence
including the fact that some of these
people apparently are
involved in the democrat party in
virginia
seems to be very good evidence that uh
the democrats and mcauliffe the malcolm
campaigner some people at least
associate with mccall of campaign were
involved in this that would be my
assumption
um a never trump advisor with the
lincoln project was on cnn with chris
cuomo a couple days later and here he is
explaining and justifying this quote
unquote stunt
some people showed up at a yunkan event
posing as charlottesville
protesters uh a group you're with the
lincoln project owned that it was them
that they posed this way because they
wanted people to remember
are you getting crushed by people on the
right uh as a dirty tactic do you stand
behind what was done and is that being
what you guys say you oppose
um no listen every day uh i hear people
pleading with the lincoln project to
help show democrats how to win how to
play hardball um
you know
this is an example
the the question here is it's not about
some guys who showed up at a rally it's
why hasn't glenn younken denounced
donald trump for saying that there were
good people on both sides i mean that is
absolutely outrageous and it's because
glenn young wants it both ways and i
think that's the message that needs to
be driven here you know the the lincoln
project was the first in this race to
put charlottesville in an ad
and some people thought maybe it went
too far but we did it and it worked and
then mcauliffe campaign followed us and
put charlottesville in a very good ad
they did so i think the question here is
we can't ignore what happened in
charlottesville the question is why
hasn't glenn duncan denounced donald
trump
yes why hasn't he denounced denounce
downs you have to just
keep that that's what you're all if
you're a republican
that's that's what's expected of you by
the left your entire if you're running
for office your entire campaign should
consist of denouncing
um all of the bad things that have
allegedly happened on your side uh even
if those things are you know
are aren't true it doesn't matter what
it is
we know the fine people comment has been
taken wildly out of context
um by the left but that's all you're
supposed to do as a republican is just
keep on denouncing
um you're supposed to have a campaign
completely on the defensive
um
and really your as far as the left goes
your pitch is supposed to be
that um as a republican you know
i'm not as bad as the other republicans
that should be your only pitch these
other republicans are horrible i'm not
as horrible as them
that's and that's what the lincoln
project wants
and they they claim that i i hope that
what he just said there was true
that democrats are coming to them
asking
the lincoln project to show them how to
win
i i hope that they are
what the hell does a lincoln project
know about what exactly have they won
what have they achieved they've enriched
themselves that's for sure
this and this is not uh this is not
exactly playing hardball this is again
fraud
and we can i have to always say it
as futile as as it may be to say to
point out
we can only imagine
some if something like that had happened
similar to that analogous to it on the
other side
it would be the lead story
across the media spectrum be the only
thing they're talking about
and this would be this would be framed
as a purposeful act of fraud
meant to uh
influence an election
which is exactly what it is
what about denouncing that has terry
mcauliffe denounce this quote unquote
stunt
well that's part of the game
democrats don't have to denounce
anything and republicans are supposed to
do nothing but denounce and and and by
the way even after you've denounced
something
that's not enough you have to keep on
denouncing it
which is why uh things that donald
donald trump who is not president
anymore
things he said
four years ago
you have to continually denounce even
now
as you run for governor of virginia as
if any of that is relevant
okay next we have uh from the daily wire
it says after a southwest airlines pilot
reportedly ended an address to
passengers with the words let's go
brandon on friday a cnn analyst cnn
analyst likened the man's remark to the
equivalence of something an isis
terrorist might say
colleen long of the associated press
said that the incident took place friday
morning on a flight from houston
albuquerque
video subsequently uh subsequently
surfaced of an unidentified pilot
uttering the anti-biden phrase after
welcoming the passengers to the flight
thanks for coming out and flying south
south southwest airlines welcome aboard
he said and remember uh let's go brandon
cnn analyst aisha uh rangapa promptly
referenced the murderous isis terrorist
group while addressing the pilot's
reported comment on social media she
says quote as an experiment i'd love for
a southwest airlines pilot to say long
live isis before taking off
my guess is that the uh that one the
plane would be immediately grounded
two the pilot fired and three a
statement issued by the airline within a
matter of hours
and this wasn't even the most
supercharged overheated comparison made
uh there was someone else some other
media analyst who compared it said that
let's go brandon is the siege heil now
of of the uh of the right wing
you know which
many
many crucial differences there
but here's one
let's go brandon
is a criticism of the president it's not
a it's not a
this is not a statement of loyalty
to a tyrant in office
this is a criticism of authority
and we also have to keep in mind that
this is all that
the claim that a southwest pilot said
let's go brandon
is right now
just a claim
there is a video that surfaced and it's
kind of weird and it's not clear where
this video came from it's it's a video
from the cockpit
who was taking that video why was it
released i mean we don't know exactly
you always have to leave open the
possibility given the source
that none of this even happened
but also if it did happen
who cares
ev every
nearly every major corporation in
america
is firmly on the left
constantly and consistently pledging
their undying fealty loyalty to to the
left
coming out in support of radical
left-wing causes and organizations like
black lives matter
that's every single corporation nearly
every corporation
so that everywhere you go
including in airports and on airplanes
and everywhere else you go in society
this is the message you hear being
rammed into your eardrums everywhere
it's
promotion of left-wing causes left-wing
propaganda
from all of the wealthiest and most
powerful voices and institutions in
america and then you have one pilot
on one plane
for one airline
who says let's go brandon allegedly and
this is a this is a major crisis
and and suddenly now there's no place
for this suddenly there's no place for
employees and people you know and for
companies
who are not associated with politics
there's no no place for any kind of
political statements
now there's no place for it
it is an interesting question why
uh
maybe it's not so interesting maybe
maybe the answer is pretty obvious but
the left they really hate this let's go
brandon thing
i think they tried to ignore it for a
while
and uh they but they they can't help
themselves they can't ignore anything
for very long
and now
now they're engaging with it and uh
of course going way over the top and
this is this is like the nazis this is
like being an isis
why do they hate it so much i think they
hate it because number one it's it is
it's clever
it's funny and clever
and they hate that about it
and it's something that developed
organically
you know again with the left owning all
of the major institutions they can try
to create memes
you know they can kind of force these
things into the public public
consciousness this is something that
happened organically
this is this is very much a grassroots
meme
and this was the
this is the
you know the public flipping something
around on the media
we all we all remember where this all
this all began when people are chanting
f joe biden and then someone some news
anchor says oh it sounds like they're
saying let's go brandon
and then it becomes
very much an organic thing that develops
and it's funny and it's clever but also
it goes back to what i said a few days
ago
and i think this is a really important
point
that um the let's go brandon stuff
it's more vulgar cousin f joe biden
it makes joe
biden it makes a mockery of him
you know it makes him seem
like a just a clown like a sort of
ridiculous pitiful
figure
which he is
he's also dangerous
and he represents something dangerous
because of the power that he has and the
ways that he's using it
and the way that he's allowing other
people around him to use to use that
power
but that doesn't change the fact that he
is
he's a clown he's a pitiful person
he's a joke
and that's
it's really hard to come back from that
politically
being criticized as a tyrant being
criticized as you know abusing your
power
dishonest all those kinds of things
those are pretty standard accusations in
the political realm
and if you're a politician and you're
and that's in those labels and
accusations are being tossed at you by
the other side you can deal with that
that's that's par for the course
but when they're able to successfully
make you into a clown
into a mockery
um
that is hard to recover from
and i think that i think the left
realizes that
and that's why they're they're panicking
over this is why we should continue
continue to uh wave our let's go brandon
flags high and proudly
uh what else do we got here
let's see this is also about the
virginia race it says from the ap for
four years nothing rallied democrats
like the push to get donald trump out of
office now they're not sure what to do
without him democrats in virginia are
scrambling to stave off disaster in the
state's governor's race the most
competitive major election since trump
left the white house the surprisingly
tight contest has exposed the depth of
the party's dependence on trump as a
message and motivator without him top of
mind for many and with headwinds from
washington democratic officials
privately fear they may lose their first
statewide election in virginia in more
than a decade on tuesday
public polling has been shifting and
republican newcomer glenn younkin's
direction in recent weeks while democrat
terry mcauliffe former governor close
ally of president joe biden has
struggled to energize his base as
biden's approval ratings sink
um and so they're they're panicking and
you know i don't want to start spiking
the football too early
um especially when we've seen what what
democrats are willing to do we've seen
the fraud that they already
perpetrated
a confirmed fraud
so that's one of many reasons not to
spike the football too early but
uh
there are some very positive indications
here
even even if
if glenn younkin loses in the end
which he could obviously it's a tight
race he could lose
but even if he does
you know this is much closer than it was
supposed to be
he's still got all the momentum on his
side
and he generated that momentum a little
bit late in the game
how did he generate it we already talked
about it he generated but generated it
by
breaking away from the kind of standard
republican mold
and instead embracing cultural issues
and the moment that he did that and this
education thing is very much a cultural
issue
uh especially because the one of the the
primary concerns parents have about the
indoctrination of kids
about the the values and world views
that are being imposed on their children
critical race theory gender ideology and
so on
you know a hatred for
america and it's in its uh in its
history and its culture these are all
cultural issues
so the
the moment glen young can embrace that
and this this happened kind of late in
the game but that's when all the
momentum shifted
so if in the end he loses one of the
things that will tell us is well if he
had done that from the start of the race
had enough time to build the momentum to
where it needed to be he probably would
have won
so either way that's that's one of the
lessons we take win or lose
that's one of the lessons we have to
take from this
also he didn't allow the race to be
about trump
you know a lot of republicans have taken
the wrong lessons from trump's victory
in 2016.
and uh they think that in order to win
and to appeal to their base they you
know they also have to make it all about
trump
and talk about trump all the time and
constantly express their undying loyalty
to trump the man and the democrats love
that because all they want as even the
ap report admits all they want to do is
talk about trump that's the only thing
they know how to do
you know donald trump came along five
six years ago and very quickly
redefined everything for the left
and that he has become their
their central focus
and the only thing they know how to do
is run against him and criticize him
and criticize other people in terms of
donald trump
this is something that mccullough has
been doing and it's just it's just
laughable to see he's been trying
desperately
to paint mcauliffe as this radical trump
supporting but
rather to play paint junkin as you know
as a
donald trump's right-hand man or
something
meanwhile youngkin is going around
talking about issues that that matter to
people in virginia talking about
education talking about these cultural
issues
it's got nothing to do with donald trump
so there are lessons that republicans
can take
from
trump's approach to things
you know there are good lessons and bad
lessons
as trump has positive and negative
points
but it's the wrong lesson if they think
that okay the way to win is to make is
to allow the democrats to make this all
about trump
glenn yonkin hasn't allowed that and uh
that's what has
flipped everything on its head
in uh in virginia okay finally here
we'll go back to an airplane this is
this is a story from an airplane that i
think is uh actually interesting from
the new york post it says new release
new newly released footage of a glowing
orb over mexico has been called very
consistent with decades of previous
reports of unidentified aerial phenomena
uaf which is what they call ufos now
this was a video obtained by the daily
mail it shows a pulsating teardrop
shaped object
zip around a pair of pilots who spotted
the ufo on march 19th 2020.
can we let's take a look at this video
we got video here to play
shooting star but then it stopped you
can hear the pilots talking about it
zoom in man
it's like an orb man look at that
it's pulsating
oh this is awesome
and he's not on tcas man
these these are the pilots in the plane
right now okay
well i can tell rita now
there's the orb you see it i mean it's a
glow they're you know they're 30 000
feet in the air or whatever and they see
this orb floating around
latinos
these a pulsating orb look at that dude
look at that
you know i'm not disturbed at all by the
by the let's go brandon thing from a
pilot
i am a little disturbed by how these
pilots are talking to each other just
only because
turn on the tail light oh it is i don't
know they sound just like normal dudes
talking to each other look at that man
and these are pilots
uh you know i don't i can't blame them
for being normal dudes but i kind of
want i will you know i i want my pilot
to look and sound like
you know a mustachioed 55 year old man
from the from the 1940s that that's
that's what i
that's what i want from my pilot
and when i hear them talking to each
other just like normal guys
it disturbs me a little bit i'm not
disturbed by the ufo at all um that that
on the other hand doesn't disturb me
i've uh
as you know i'm very welcoming of our
new alien overlords and i just wish that
they would stop wasting time and get
here already uh all right let's read the
comments
who's rocking polka dots without shame
do you know their names
they're the sweet baby gang
delaney stevens says almost 100 correct
on your history points the polynesians
did cross a whole ocean to set up a
permanent settlement it's called hawaii
also the polynesians were like one of
the most violent and subjugation-centric
empires in the history of the world
that professor is an effing clown well
yeah i guess you could get into
splitting hairs and semantics about what
counts as crossing a whole ocean but uh
yeah there were i think i mentioned the
polynesians
when we talked about this last week
there were seafaring civilizations
um non-western
non-white uh seafaring civilizations of
course
before the europeans started settling
new the new world
um but
what what the europeans did in crossing
this
unknown ocean to this whole other to
them unknown part of the world and
setting up
a whole new civilization i mean
spreading their civilization on such a
wide scale
uh that was unique in in human history
other cultures and civilizations even
the ones that had
the ability to you know getting a ship
and sail somewhere which many did
still were not doing that
and not because again not because they
had ethical qualms with it
but just because it wasn't they didn't
have the ability to or it wasn't in
their interest
or they figured hey if we want to expand
our empire and every empire in history
has wanted to expand that's part of what
being an empire is and they said if we
want to expand our empire we can do it
on land we don't need to get in a boat
and do it
andrew says
um
quoting says denies the child exposure
to other ideas and values that an
independent young person might wish to
embrace or at least entertain
says matt i agree with the rest you said
in response to all this but right here
is where the conversation really stops i
have five children
not one of them buys their own food
house utilities car phone etc sure i as
a parent have zero right to deny any
independent young person exposure to
anything they might wish to embrace or
entertain but regarding my own children
they are not independent and of story
they are my dependents they depend upon
me unless one also wants to accuse me of
tax fraud
right and that's that's the that's one
of the problems
with this uh claim we hear from
advocates of the public school system
the advocates who want to keep parents
out of it
who say
well we we want we want children to
think into we want them to be
independent and think independently and
be free thinkers
that children do not think independently
nobody really does
especially not kids
and they don't live independently
they are in no way shape or form
independent in any sense of the word
they are going to be guided and
shaped
and coached along
and their worldview is inevitably
going to be something largely given to
them and as they get older
you know they might adjust they might
abandon that world view entirely they
might adjust it they might you know
they're gonna make their own unique
tweaks to it
as they develop their own perspective of
the world
but kids don't come into the world
having a perspective a fully formed
perspective of the world
that is given to them the question is is
it going to primarily be given to them
by their parents or by the government
that's the question
um
elizabeth says matt i can attest i
learned more from you than from any of
my professors at college unfortunately a
matt walsh degree doesn't pay the bills
or find you a husband or i would
absolutely quit college in favor of your
show
yeah i'm not going to claim that my show
will accomplish that for you but then
again a university degree doesn't do
that either in many cases unfortunately
um
steve a says matt i've been noticing
more and more bumper stickers praising
their pets like i heart my granddog
is a particularly strange one especially
if this person has grandchildren
granddog
i didn't know that was a thing
and now i do so thank you for that i
have one more reason to despair of this
world and to beg for those aliens to
finally show up
um
njl says matt what are all of your kids
going as for halloween you don't strike
me as the kind of dad who coordinates a
family costume theme uh you're correct
as always i you know go i go as a guy
named matt that's my costume my oldest
daughter went as a witch
my youngest daughter was a baby shark
my oldest son was uh huckleberry finn
because he's a big fan of the book which
i mentioned before and we read books in
our family we don't play video games we
don't watch a lot of tv so
these are the kinds of things my kids
are interested my youngest son went as a
werewolf originally he wanted to be a
gingerbread man and change it to the
last minute that's one of the things
about halloween
one of the constants
is that your kid will always change
their mind about their costume at the
last minute
they're going to change their mind
half of the costume costume is going to
be lost
so you know that's going to happen and
whatever costume they ultimately wear
they're going to shed about half of it
12 minutes into trick-or-treating
because it's hot and itchy and they
don't want to wear it anymore
because you know leading up to halloween
all the emphasis is on the costumes it's
a big deal you know we got to find the
costume what am i going to be for
halloween and as a kid this this is a
this this is a very important decision
brings them a lot of anxiety they spend
months thinking about it and talking
about what costume they're going to be
but then when the big night comes
all of that for frivolity is thrown to
the side and it's only about the candy
so all they care about is just running
up to as many houses they can with and
getting the candy and so by the end of
it like at the last house your kids
aren't hardly wearing any costume at all
uh it's only the candy
it's just a it's a matter of pure
efficiency um
and which i appreciate because you know
the more candy they collect
the more that
i get to steal
ultimately and i need them to collect a
lot because i know that a big percentage
of the candy that they that they bring
in the input is going to be crappy stuff
like milk duds and smarties way too much
of that and so i need i need a a large
volume so that there's more of the
diamonds in the rough you know the
snickers the twix all that swedish fish
and so on
uh and from and i explained this to my
kids by the way i told them you know
it probably won't happen
but you do hear about cases of people
poisoning candy
and from what i've read
you know things like snickers bars and
milky ways and twixes and that sort of
thing especially the big candy bars any
of the good big candy bars um those are
more likely to be poisoned from what
i've read so it's best for me i'll just
take those i'll you know i'll consume
them i'll take the hit
and you know it's just one more
sacrifice i have to make as a father if
you haven't heard about this app yet let
me do you a favor and tell you about it
it's called get upside my listeners are
making up to 25 cents for every gallon
of gas every time they fill up with this
app just download the free get upside
app in the app store google play right
now use promo code walsh and get a bonus
25 cents per gallon on your first fill
up that's up to 50 cents cash back don't
pay full price of the pump anymore get
cash back using get upside there's just
within with gas prices skyrocketing you
need to save all the money you possibly
can just download the app for free and
use promo code walsh to get up to 50
gallon a gallon cash back on your first
tank and then 25 cents a gallon
thereafter some people who drive a lot
are making as much as two to three
hundred dollars a month in cash back and
there's no catch okay i know you hear
something about it like this and you're
thinking okay what's the catch what's
the
you know where's the fine print where
all this falls apart uh it isn't there
it's as simple as that the cashback gets
added right to your account you can cash
out any time to your bank account paypal
or an e gift card for amazon and other
brands just download the free get upside
app and use promo code walsh to save up
to 50
per gallon cash back on your first tank
that's code walsh get upside app and
also tomorrow night
your very own native virginia resident
that's me will sit back and watch the
election results in an exciting
real-time live stream come watch with me
over at dailywire.com at 7 30 pm eastern
6 30 p.m central time this election will
be fascinating to watch especially as i
have personally spoken at the loudoun
county school board meeting about their
policies that are destroying children's
lives really you might say that this
election is uh is all about me you know
it's not about trump it's not it's not
even about glenn young or terry
mccullough i think actually in the end
it's all about me daily wire has also
broken a major news story about the same
county in the last few weeks and that
same school board covering up sexual
assault to further their own political
agenda so if you want to stay in the
loop or and also on more breaking news
from daily wire join now a membership is
as little as 40 a month and you can get
25 off now using promo code real news so
join today and watch with me tomorrow
night at dailywire.com
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
for the daily cancellation today i must
sadly cancel many of you in the audience
for your involvement
in a totally disgraceful and
disappointing display over the weekend
it all began when rumors started
circulating online
that president biden tragically pooped
his pants while visiting with the pope
in rome amy tarkanian a political
strategist and pundit was one of the
first to make this odorous allegation
tweeting quote the word around rome is
that biden's meeting with the pope was
unusually long because biden had a bit
of a bathroom accident at the vatican
and it had to be addressed prior to him
leaving i know we joke often about this
but this is the actual rumor going
around rome now
next thing you know
hashtags like hashtag poop gate and
hashtag poopypants biden and the more
direct hashtag bite and [ __ ] is pants
we're trending nationwide on twitter
other sources were you know chiming in
all claiming that yes joe biden did
indeed drop a steamy load in his pants
right in front of pope francis
and then millions of other people
with no special knowledge about the
situation people with no specific
insights into joe biden's defecation
habits at all frankly
still were posting about the subject
spreading this insidious rumor
and to once again clarify by insidious
rumor i am referring to the claim that
joe biden pooped himself at the vatican
that's the rumor
and personally i'm outraged and
disgusted by all this
it is the absolute height of your
responsibility to spread rumors of this
sort
there is no legitimate reason to call
attention to the issue of joe biden
himself no reason
you know someone has to be the mature
one in this situation and as usual that
job has fallen to me which is why i am
not talking about the subject of joe
biden soiling himself
i would never talk about something so
crass and objectionable and
unsubstantiated we don't even know if
joe biden really did poop his pants
there are some people saying he pooped
his pants others saying that he didn't
poop his pants
still there are others saying that we
have no idea what joe biden did or
didn't do in his pants
in the face of this uncertainty
the dignified and honest thing is to say
nothing at all
i am therefore begging all of you to not
talk about this
and if you didn't know about it until
you just heard about it right now
don't talk about it it's not the kind of
thing we should be discussing which is
why i have personally chosen to do my
part by not calling attention to it at
all it's better if the public never even
hears about this rumor
the rumor that joe biden president
united states pooped himself so please
once again
just don't talk about it in fact shortly
before we went on air um i noticed
another hashtag associated with the
poopypants predicament a large number of
social media users have apparently
caused the hashtag shartweek to trend
this is not only potential
misinformation but it also makes light
of the trauma suffered by actual shark
attack victims
and actual shark attack victims
that's why i would never extend this pun
by saying that the vatican became
something of a shark tank when biden
arrived
that's a joke i'm not going to make
there are many other presidential poop
jokes that
i will not make
and would be very angry to hear anyone
make for example i'm not gonna say that
through his eight years as vice
president biden apparently got
accustomed to being the number two guy
in the white house i'm not gonna say i'm
not gonna say that biden flew back from
rome in air force two i'm not gonna say
that involuntary defecation must be a
hereditary problem for biden since it
runs in his genes
these would be vulgar and unfunny jokes
and i'm not gonna make them or any other
because there's nothing funny about a
turd
especially a turd in the pants of the
president
allegedly
now all we know for sure
the only thing we should be saying about
biden's visit with the pope
is that he went there in his official
capacity as a president united states
and he did his duty
that's it
outside of that our responsibility is to
comport ourselves with maturity and
dignity and respect the office of the
presidency and we should still respect
the office even if that man in that
office happens to have evacuated his
bowels right into his underwear
you know i don't care if biden did have
a literal holy moment in front of the
pope that doesn't change anything
except his diaper
as for the rest of us we have to be
adults about this
and the fact is that many of you have
failed in that regard you have used
biden's poo filled pants as a forum for
jokes and mockery rather than gazing
upon them in solemn silence as is your
duty and his apparently allegedly
and for that
all of you today are canceled
shame on you
shame on you
and that'll do it for us today
we'll leave it there thanks for watching
thanks for listening have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producer is mathis glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadosky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
ibram candy accidentally disproves
systemic racism democrats send fake
white supremacists to a republican rally
in virginia and the media dubbed let's
go brandon a nazi chant check it out on
the michael knowles show